c'est officiel depuis lundi 17 mai au
soir les listes pour les élections
régionales ont été officiellement
déposée en ile-de-france cette liste
vont concourir pour la gouvernance de la
région capitale
tour d'horizon des têtes de listes
candidat à la présidence mais aussi des
postulants yvelinois valérie pécresse
repart présidente du parti libre et
présidente sortante du conseil régional
elle est candidate à sa réélection avec
la liste ile de france rassemblée elle
est également tête de liste dans les
yvelines
à ses côtés dans le département pas de
changement othman nasri premier vice
président sortant et conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes se
place en deuxième position suivi
d'alexandra dublanche adjointe au maire
à sartrouville est elle aussi
vice-présidente sortante du côté de la
majorité présidentielle c'est le député
du val de marne et rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée nationale lors en
sang martin qui conduira la liste envie
d'ile-de-france pour la république en
marche dans les yvelines il a investi
jean-noël barrot député modem de la 2e
circonscription en tant que tête de
liste
aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription se place à la deuxième
position
à gauche l'ancien journaliste et
actuelle adjointe au maire d'anne
hidalgo à paris audrey pulvar se lance
dans la bataille des régionales avec la
liste ile-de-france en commun investie
par le parti socialiste
elle a choisi dieynaba diop porte parole
du ps dans les yvelines et conseillère
municipale aux mureaux pour représenter
sa liste dans le département en deuxième
position ce sera eddie aït maire de
carrières sous poissy et conseiller
régional sortant
pas d'alliance avec le ps dont pour
europe ecologie les verts le conseiller
régional sortant et secrétaire nationale
du parti écologiste julien bayou se
présente à la présidence de
l'ile-de-france avec l'écologie
évidemment pour les ter évinoise
ghislaine tuner et conseillère régionale
sortante et ancien maire des vêtements
sera tête de liste en numéro 2 benoît
hamon de génération ancien député des
yvelines et ancien candidat aux
présidentielles
il a préféré e élevés plutôt que le ps à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique le
rassemblement national jordan bardella
vice-président du parti de marine le pen
mais aussi député européen et conseiller
régional sortant a présenté sa liste le
choix de la sécurité dans les yvelines
pas de surprise le
responsable 78 du parti frontiste
laurent maurin et tête de liste suivi en
troisième position de cyril notre ancien
maire de mantes-la-jolie seules communes
d'île de france affilié rassemblement
national entre 2014 et 2020 à l'extrême
gauche de liste d'abord pouvoir vivre en
ile de france celle de la france
insoumise avec clémentine autain député
de la seine-saint-denis allié au parti
communiste français la liste investi
nelly duthu ancien maire de la verrière
et membre du comité exécutif du pcf
comme tête de liste yvelinoise sébastien
ramage conseiller municipal elle est
fille à lui en cours sera son numéro
deux enfin la septième et dernière lice
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
et celle de nathalie arthaud porte
parole de lutte ouvrière dans les
yvelines jean pierre mercier l'ancien
candidat lutte ouvrière aux municipales
2020 à poissy et tête de liste en numéro
deux une factrice à la retraite
hélène janis et